bonjour les genres chose premier chose
due voici enfin la vidéo pour apprendre
les cannas et surtout pour les mémoriser
sur le long terme donc bien évidemment
je vais vous montrer quelques démos
techniques pour vous permettre de
mémoriser les cannas de façon visuelle
mais je vais aussi vous donner des
astuces pour les fixer dans notre
mémoire à long terme attention cette
méthode marche pour absolument tout si
vous avez quoi que ce soit à apprendre
par coeur que vous devez mémorisées vous
pouvez utiliser cette technique donc
rester jusqu'à la fin sur ce on ne perd
pas plus de temps c'est parti générique
[Musique]
pour commencer faisons un petit tour
d'horizon vous avez certainement
remarqué qu'il y a trois systèmes
d'écriture en japonais les kanjis mais
si la ghana et les katakana on va
laisser les conduits de côté pour le
moment alors quelle est la différence
entre les fils à gannat et les katakana
les fils à gannat servent tout
simplement à écrire les mots qui sont
typiquement japonais les katakana sont
utilisés pour écrire les onomatopées
mais également tous les mots d'origine
étrangère par exemple les prénoms
occidentaux comme le mien le nom des
pays et des villes des pays étrangers
voilà pour la petite explication ou vite
fait maintenant on va entrer dans le
détail
[Musique]
on va commencer par les fils à gannat ce
qu'on appelle les cannes a donc laissé
la ghana et les katakana ce sont en fait
des syllabes donc ce n'est pas tout à
fait un alphabet mais plutôt un système
si la mer vous allez comprendre très
rapidement si vous regardez le petit
tableau vous avez des consonnes et des
voyelles et quand on mixe les deux ça
donne des sons et donc des syllabes dans
la première rangée on a à y ou est au
ensuite on n'a qu'à qui que
keko ensuite
ça 6 alors oui là il faut le noter il
n'ya pas le son si le sens il n'existe
pas pour la simple et bonne raison que
pour un japonais si et chis exactement
la même chose donc retenez simplement le
son si ensuite on a sous ses esso
[Musique]
ensuite tu as là encore il y a un petit
twist sur la ligne de hi
ce n'est pas tim et si encore une fois
les japonais ne prononce pas
spécifiquement le säntis ils disent si
ensuite il y a encore une petite
variable le sont eux n'existent pas
c'est le son se ensuite on a des taux
line suivante n'a ni ne n'ai non à 6
attention ce n'est pas cool mais fou en
fait c'est entre le match et le f
ensuite on a créé et ensuite on a co
[Musique]
à
et
attention à cette ligne surtout pour les
francophones on ne prononce pas les h or
c'est une grosse erreur il faut
absolument prononcé le h10 est différent
de fille je vais vous donner un exemple
très simple et be c'est une crevette
febit c'est un serpent donc si vous
allez au restaurant en disant que vous
êtes allergique aux serpents mais que
vous avez peur des crevettes on risque
de vous regarder bizarrement donc
prononcé bien le cas à six coups des
eaux exercez-vous à souffler je sais ce
n'est pas forcément très élégant vous
allez peut-être faire une
hyperventilation à force de le faire
mais il faut vraiment prendre l'habitude
de les prononcer sinon vous allez dire
des mots qui sont totalement différent
de ce que vous voulez dire on continue
ma mie me mets mot sur la ligne d y il
n'y a que trois syllabes ya you you
ensuite la
d2 les lots
[Musique]
et
alors le son air à la française le ça
n'existe pas en japonais d'ailleurs
c'est ce qui leur pose la plus grosse
difficulté quand ils apprennent à
prononcer le français se le sont le 1 er
et le elle c'est exactement la même
chose d'ailleurs le saut r pour nous
c'est entre le r roulés et le n un petit
peu comme en espagnol donc on dit pas à
rire ou rero ne fait surtout pas ça il
vaut mieux dire là lille où les lots là
les gens vous vous comprendre mais sinon
si vous voulez essayer de le prononcer
le plus exactement possible c'est
vraiment entre le 1er et le m là les le
vélo et enfin les dernières syllabes ou
à eau et attention le son est bien une
syllabe à part entière il faut l'a
prononcée lorsque vous la voyez dans un
mot par exemple dans le mot on a une
femme on ne dit pas ona mais oh
non il y à bien trois syllabes dans
trois temps et donc 3 prononciation bien
distinguent on a alors vous avez
remarqué que le sont eux n'existent pas
en japonais d'ailleurs ça aussi c'est
une difficulté pour les japonais ils ne
savent pas prononcé le sont eux ils
savent dire ou au mais le e71 piège dans
lequel ils tombent systématiquement il
se tend de la langue dessus
[Musique]
oh
oh oh
donc à chaque fois que vous voyez un e
ça se prononce et autres petites choses
à savoir le son ou vous pouvez tout à
fait dire 'oui' mais si vous voulez
entrer dans une prononciation plus exact
il faudrait dire euh c'est entre le ou
et le u peut par contre ne dites surtout
pas pu par exemple où les chi content
heureux ça ne se dit pas eu les chi
donc dans le doute il vaut mieux dire où
les chi vous êtes sûr au moins que tout
le monde va vous comprendre ça c'était
pour les petites subtilités
[Musique]
il
alors pourquoi créer des mémos de
techniques visuelles tout simplement
parce que ça vous retient plus
facilement ce qui est concret or les
caractères japonais sont très abstrait
en tout cas pour nous donc il faut les
rendre concret il faut que notre cerveau
puisse faire des associations pour
pouvoir les mémoriser donc si vous
associez un nouveau son ou un nouveau
mot avec une image concrète et même si
possible avec des émotions vous êtes sûr
que votre cerveau val imprimés de façon
très profonde
alors on va commencer avec la première
ligne le son à monts premier mémo
technique c'est quelqu'un qui dit aïe
alors je ne sais pas si vous visualisez
mais on a effectivement
la barre des yeux qui est comme ça le
nez et la bouche grande ouverte
donc pensez vraiment à quelqu'un qui a
très mal imaginez vous même en train
d'avoir mal si vous pouvez associer des
émotions ou des sensations vous à les
mémoriser de façon plus profonde et plus
facile
[Musique]
ensuite on a l'oeil alors oui je le mime
extrait il dit quand je souris et quand
je rigole et que je fais au mieux j'ai
deux petites rides ici là comme le
smiley donc ce sont ces deux petites
rides ici qui font le pays
pour le sont eux qu'on peut dire où on
imagine un personnage qui fait oulala
donc ou avec les sourcils bien écartées
et la bouche
en forme de cul de poule donc n'oubliez
pas le petit sourcils au dessus de la
bouche ou
foot
[Musique]
ensuite on a le et alors là on peut
penser un éléphant mais un éléphant un
petit peu vénère vous voyez les sourcils
un petit peu français là comme ça donc
il faut y penser parce que c'est ce qui
fait la petite partie du dessus et
ensuite on a ça trompe il fait cette
forme souvenez vous également si vous ne
voulez pas oublier le petit accent au
dessus ça fait également penser à
l'accent aigu qu'on a sur le e quand on
veut transformer un e en est en français
on mais bien un accent aigu au dessus et
bien pensé que le et il y a un petit
accent aigu au dessus ça vous évitera de
l'oublier
[Musique]
ensuite on a le haut donc là c'est
quelqu'un qui dit oh mais en mode un peu
triste il pleure un petit peu vous voyez
donc il a accepté sourcils pareil qui
robic comme ça on a sonné
et on a ça bouge qui fait un mot et si
vous ne voulez pas oublier la petite
goutte qui est sur le côté vous pouvez
imaginer que ce sont ces petites larmes
justement qui tombe donc ça fait au
[Musique]
présent la ligne des cas car on peut
penser à un katana alors vous voyez on a
la garde on a la lame et on a une petite
goutte de sang donc ça c'est le son cas
[Musique]
foot
ensuite on à qui alors pour celui-là
j'ai deux niveaux techniques soit vous
pensez à quelqu'un qui joue au bowling
et lorsqu'ils envoient la boule ça fait
exploser toutes les qui dans tous les
sens donc on a deux qui en dessus une
qui est presque verticale est en dessous
on a la boule donc ça fait bien le
sinon vous pouvez également penser à qui
les clés en anglais là il faut penser
aux vieilles clés donc celles qui sont
en métal qui sont bien grosse donc avec
deux bâtons généralement c'est ceux qui
s'insèrent effectivement dans la serrure
la tige centrale est généralement
dessous il ya une sorte d'anneau là vous
pouvez effectivement visualiser une clé
qui
[Musique]
pour que j'ai deux ou trois
mnémotechnique alors le premier mois qui
me venu c'est le fait que cette partie
là c'est une partie de la lettre qu'a
donc le cas de co sinon vous pouvez
penser à quelqu'un quitte werc avec son
cul et enfin un troisième démo technique
vous pouvez penser à quelqu'un qui est
courbé parce qu'il a mal au cul
[Musique]
pour quai on peut penser à un kebab donc
vous avez sur le côté le couteau qui
sert à couper le kebab et à côté on a la
pièce de viande qui est accroché
[Musique]
et
enfin qu pour cela moi je pense
accueille les carpes koï donc on a un
premier poisson en eau et un deuxième en
bas je sais pas si vous voyez un petit
peu souvent comme dans le sine in ayant
un comme ça hein comme ça c'est comme ça
que j'arrive à mémoriser le co
[Musique]
ensuite ça alors je pense à de la salade
dans un saladier ça donc imaginez
quelqu'un qui a une cuillère dans la
main la plonge dans un saladier pour
prendre de la salade
si je pense à chimie et en l'occurrence
à la petite éprouvette vous voyez donc
le chi épouse la forme de la petite
éprouvette
[Musique]
ce oussou donc la pine qui refait son
apparition mais il a mis un petit
t-shirt et on voit sa queue en tire
bouchon en dessous donc sous le tee
shirt il y à la petite que
sous le tee shirt il y a la petite cup
merci bing
[Musique]
c'est vous pouvez penser un sécateur
donc vous avez bien en dessus les deux
petites lames qui coupent ensuite on a
la partie horizontale ce qui relie un
petit peu le tout et dessous vous avez
les deux poignets
[Musique]
pour le tas c'est très simple si vous
regardez bien ça ressemble aux lettres t
et à en français la barre horizontale du
thé la barre verticale du thé et en
dessous on a quelque chose qui ressemble
un petit peu un an ça fait le sont pas
[Musique]
6 alors moi je pense à ti dancho beats
alors moi je visualise la ligne avec ses
deux petites oreilles son coup et c'est
vous parce que witschi elle est
vachement beau laid mais vous pouvez
également penser au chiffre 5 ce que
vous regardez ça ressemble bien un
chiffre 5 et vous pouvez même mixer les
deux le chief
re5
[Musique]
ce il est relativement facile vous
pouvez penser à la vague du tsunami
[Musique]
d alors moi je vois une forme à peu près
équivalent de la lettre t en français
donc vous voyez la barre horizontale et
la barre verticale ma le thé japonais il
se met un petit peu là voilà
[Musique]
et
enfin le taux je pense un taureau donc
on a la petite corne ici et ici on à son
museau tôt
[Musique]
pour le napt on peut penser à napoléon
tient la main comme ça fier et droit sur
son cheval donc la ligne horizontale
c'est la ligne du bras la ligne
verticale c'est le corps ensuite on a la
petite oreille du cheval ou le début de
sa tête comme vous voulez et la petite
forme en boucle ça fait son temps cela
sa partie un petit peu bombé la de son
plastron avec le début de la patte avant
le lever
[Musique]
dans la précipitation j'ai oublié le nid
alors ni c'est très simple je pense à un
nid d'oiseau qui est posée sur un arbre
donc vous avez la ligne qui est
totalement à gauche c'est l'arbre est à
côté vous avez le nid ça donne le son ni
nous alors il n'est pas vraiment facile
à mémoriser celui là donc moi je pense
plutôt à quelque chose qui est nous est
donc un gros sac de noeuds donc vous
avez un premier ne ici ensuite vous en
avez un deuxième comme ça et qui refait
encore une boucle donc il est vraiment
très en mêlée ça fait ne
[Musique]
pour mais je pense à neko chat donc on
visualise le corps du chat
sa tête
son dos sa patte arrière et petites
astuces pensait qu'un chat il a une que
je vous dis ça pour quoi parce que le
sont les est assez similaire ce qui
permet de repérer le nez c'est qu'il a
une que comme le chat n'est qu'au
et enfin nos pour le no il faut
visualiser deux anneaux entremêlées à
nous non au milieu on a bien le nino
[Musique]
on continue avec la ligne dh donc on a
le a donc moi je pense à une harpiste
qui joue de la harpe donc la première
ligne verticale ici c'est le début de l'
as
ici on a le bras de la harpiste et son
corps et la petite boucle c'est parce
qu'elle a les genoux pliés parce qu'elle
est assise
donc je pense à la barre oui je prononce
bien à je souffle
[Musique]
ensuite on a le chic de sipopo tam donc
là c'est très simple vous avez ces deux
petites oreilles et que vous avez son
gros museau un peu euros donc ça fait
bien six comme hippopotames
[Musique]
pour foot j'ai deux démos techniques à
vous proposer en promis on peut penser à
quelqu'un un petit peu fou qui danse
comme ça avec son chapeau donc on a le
chapeau comme sakhir vite la forme un
petit peu lever comme ça c'est son corps
un peu entortillé parce qu'ils dansent
et justement à côté ce sont ces petits
bras qui s'agite donc on peut penser un
fou qui danse avec son petit chapeau ça
fait cool sinon vous pouvez également
penser au monde fou dit tout simplement
vous avez en eau le petit nuage au
dessus du mont fuji en dessous vous
avais le centre de la montagne et sur
les côtés vous avez bien la délimitation
des flancs de la montagne ça peut vous
aider à mémoriser la syllabe fou
[Musique]
alors il faut penser un saut de haies ou
un seau d'eau et oui j'insiste donc vous
imaginez un petit personnage qui saute
une haie et ses jambes font cette
formule a fait
[Musique]
l'euro alors moi je pense un hôtel donc
un hôtel oui j'insiste encore sur le
march donc vous avez sur le côté la
ligne du bâtiment les deux traits ce
sont les deux étages où il ya les
fenêtres ensuite vous avez l'autre ligne
qui délimite l'autre partie du bâtiment
et au milieu vous avez la porte alors
attention contrairement aux a dans le
chic dagana à la ligne verticale des
passes des lignes horizontales
et pas dans le cros dans l'euro le
plafond il est là et la ligne verticale
ne dépasse pas le plafond ce n'est pas
possible la ligne verticale du mur ne
peut pas dépasser le plafond du bâtiment
sinon il y à un deuxième moyen
mnémotechnique c'est que vous pouvez
basculer le fil à gannat et si vous
regardez bien ça vous donne le
trop
ça fait bien h&o en français
[Musique]
ensuite on hama alors moi pour cela je
pense au mât d'un bateau donc vous avez
le mât c'est la ligne verticale les deux
lignes horizontales ce sont les voiles
et la boucle en bas c'est la coque du
bateau donc comme dans un vrai bateau le
mât dépasse dévoile
[Musique]
pour me je pense à la note me donc vous
voyez
sur les lignes nous av
le mit avec la petite boucle il finit
sur la ligne et là vous avez le trait
vertical qui finit la partie surtout
imaginer la note me sur une partition
nous alors moi je pense à une vache qui
fait mouche alors vous pouvez la
visualiser justement on à sa tête avec
ses petites oreilles là on à sa tête
avec le tout
ensuite on a son petit buzz ou petit
ventre tout rond et enfin en haut on a
sa petite queue qui sert à chasser les
mots hong kong
[Musique]
mais je pense à une mèche d'une bombe
sauf que celle-ci elle est un petit peu
spécial elle a deux mèches vous voyez à
la une première petite mèche ici qui est
allumée et elle en a une deuxième qui
est un peu entortillé est un petit peu
plus longue à s'enflammer vous pouvez
penser à mission impossible vous savez
quand quand la mèche est en train de
s'enflammer que ça se rapproche ça se
rapproche ça se rapproche jusqu'au
moment où la bombe a explosé ça c'est le
son mais
[Musique]
bon je pense à momies dont vous voyez
bien
la momie donc on à son corps les deux
lignes horizontales ce sont ses bras
comme ça devant imhotep est la partie du
bas c'est la jambe qui remonte et le
pied qui rebiquent parce qu'elle marche
avec la jambe levée comme ça
ensuite on a ya alors là je pense à yakh
donc vous avez
le museau du yak vu un petit peu de
profils sa petite corne d'un côté et de
l'autre on a l'accord plus le début du
coup c'est le son y as
[Musique]
you alors il est pas vraiment facile
celui là donc j'ai pensé à yukata vous
savez cette espèce de petit kimono léger
comporte l'été donc vous avez le corps
de la personne c'est la ligne qui est un
petit peu verticale comme ça ici vous
avez la manche du yucatan qui pend savez
comme quand on est comme ça là est la
manche qui pend dont on a la manche est
derrière la boucle c'est le hobby vous
savez le la ceinture là avec le petit
noeud derrière voilà donc ça ça permet
de visualiser ue comme yukata
[Musique]
ensuite on a yo yo alors moi je pense à
un yoyo donc quelqu'un qui tient un yoyo
donc le fait
la main et tient le yo yo le fils
est en bas la petite boucle
c'est le yoyo en question ça ça permet
de visualiser le you
[Musique]
ensuite on a le la alors là je pense un
lapin à la peintre est mignon avec des
joues bien gonflés bien dodues un lapin
toujous flûte donc là vous avez sa
petite oreille et là vous avez ça joue
la joufflue donc faites attention parce
que le la et le tri se ressemblent pas
mal
[Musique]
lee alors il y a deux astuces pour celui
là soit c'est quelqu'un qui a trop ri et
du coup il a des rides ici sur les côtés
guy ou alors vous pouvez visualiser de
limaces
qui se rencontrent lee
le on peut penser à lunettes donc vous
avez le sourcil puis ça descend vous
avez le vert de la lunette et sur le
côté la boucle c'est l'oeil ça vous fait
la lunette le
[Musique]
bourrelet comme je voulais dit il
ressemble beaucoup au nez la seule
différence c'est qu'il n'a pas la petite
boucle derrière il n'a pas là que ce
n'est pas un chat vous pouvez le
mémoriser en imaginant sur un piquet un
lézard qui est un petit peu entortillé
mais il n'a pas tout à fait fini sa
course du coup la faim ici remis qu'un
peu
[Musique]
et enfin l'eau vous pouvez penser au
lobe de l'oreille donc là vous avez un
petit peu cette forme avec tous les
petits moulages blizzard qui a dans
l'oreille là toutes les toutes les
petites formes un petit peu particulière
donc on a ça et ensuite on a la boucle
qui finit le lobe de l'oreille
[Musique]
on termine la dernière ligne déchets la
ghana on a le son ouah il ya deux moyens
de le mémoriser soit une femme enceinte
donc vous visualisez son corps
sa poitrine et son énorme
ventre imaginer qu'elle attend des
sextuplés sont vantés les énormes et
quand on la voit les gens font hu le
deuxième moyen de le mémoriser c'est de
repenser à neko le chat de tout à
l'heure sauf que là il a le dos tourné
et surtout il n'a pas de que c'est un
chat sans que et là encore une fois on
s'exclame war donc vous visualisez son
corps sa tête son dos ou contre et il
n'a pas ce que ça donne le sont ouah
[Musique]
ensuite on a le ou alors le ou pour moi
il est relativement simple qui ressemble
à la lettre n
si vous regardez
on va le bâton le petit pont qui remonte
et la faim qui rebiquent fars sans mal à
être n donc le son
[Musique]
et pour finir web alors pour celles là
on peut imaginer un petit bonhomme qui
va se viander sur une plaque de verglas
et qui s'écrit waouh donc pour le
visualiser vous avez ses bras mais comme
ça là en équilibre
son corps
sa jambe qui est sur la plaque de
verglas et qui va commencer à ripper et
cette forme là c'est le début de la
plaque de verglas ça vous donne le haut
[Musique]
on en a terminé avec le tableau
principal mais ce n'est pas encore fini
parce qu'il y a d'autres sont
[Musique]
il ya ce qu'on appelle des peines c'est
ce qui ressemble à des guillemets et on
allait mal eux c'est les petits ronds
les tintaines et emma le serbe a modifié
la prononciation des lettres déjà
existantes sur la ligne des cas car plus
tenten s'adonne leçon gueule car tu vas
devenir gars qui va devenir guide coûts
va devenir go qui va devenir gay et co
va devenir go sur la ligne ds s plus
benton ça donne zsa zsa
[Musique]
ci devient ji le son ci n'existe pas zsa
zsa zsa
ensuite on a la ligne d'été qui va
donner dès le 2 se transforme en deux
donc on a dâ b et d'eau alors dit et the
dans l'absolu il existe mais on ne s'en
sert quasiment pas donc n'est pas
nécessairement utile de les retenir
retenez principalement da d edo ensuite
pour la ligne dh on a deux variables h+
tenten ça fait le son but as devient bas
ci devient be que devient beau et
devient b héros devient beau par contre
lorsqu'on met un mal ou après le son
crash ça fait le son peuple que son p ça
va donner pas pippo fait pau
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il manque encore quelques petits sons
qu'elles ont tort ajoutés au fur à gaza
déjà existants il s'agit du seul
argument qu'on écrit en tout petit le
pape ya le petit ue et le papillon il
plus petit gars ayant tiens qui plus
petit ou égal ou qu'ils puissent
pétillon et gadio c'est différent de
petits plus grand bien john thys ya un
gars qu'on l'a bien de siad donc dedans
de prononciation qui vient par contre
car plus petit ya fait une seule syllabe
il ya un seul temps de prononciation cas
qui use your qui y au bio bonne chose
avec de bien bio bio à galilée
ds5
show avec les penguins a dit joe daly
ddp ça
tient à l'aube était bien mieux brillant
en ligne dh tian sio sion avec le
peleton bien mieux bien avec le mal ou
bien tu le pion ensuite ali le bm bien
mieux mieux et enfin la ligue et br bien
mieux bien
attention ce n'est pas fini il ya encore
une dernière petite variable à connaître
ça y est on arrive à la fin et voici la
dernière petite chose à savoir et
ensuite vous saurez absolument comment
prononcé exactement tous les fils à
gannat et comment les écrire les
allongements alors ce sont des lettres
longue quand on les écrit en caractères
romains donc ce qu'on appelle les romane
j on utilise l'accent circonflexe
donc quand vous voyez une voyelle avec
un accent circonflexe ça veut dire que
la voyelle est une voyelle longue par
exemple au sans accent se dit oh mais au
avec l'accent cela va se dire oh
alors comment est-ce qu'on rallonge
leçon aux et le son ou eh bien on va
utiliser le fil à gannat haut et non pas
le fil à gannat haut on va pas écrire
deux fois aux eaux on va écrire au plus
haut par exemple
liot plus haut ça ne se lit pas you may
you comme dans tokyo d'ailleurs fait
très attention à ça ce n'est pas tokyo
mais d'opio il y à un allongement sur
les deux eaux
ensuite pour allonger le son et on va
utiliser le fil à gannat
donc lorsque vous voyez et plus i ça ne
se prononcent pas et y met et
par exemple scène sait on ne dit pas
cette série on est d'accord on des biens
sennecey
et enfin on a ce qu'on appelle le petit
ce alors le petit ce à quoi sert-il eh
bien il sert à doubler une consonne un
petit peu comme en français par exemple
si je vous dis je m'appelle on a bien de
paix et de zèle du coup ça ne se
prononcent pas je m'appelle mais je
m'appelle c'est un petit peu le même
principe par exemple un mot qu'on a déjà
vu qui est l'école
gatx corp
ça ne se dit pas gacko méga co voyez le
son il rebondit un peu c'est comme si je
le retenais pour le rebondir après gas
co de son erreur blondie et d'ailleurs
si vous avez remarqué à la fin le son
eau est allongée ce n'est pas le gac au
méga picot et il est bien allongé avec
lequel haganah ou
en barre d'infos vous avez le lien de
mon your type et sur youtube il y a
justement les fiches récapitulatives de
tous les fils à gannat que nous avons vu
aujourd'hui donc vous avez les schémas
et les explications de cette façon si
vous ne vous souvenez plus d'un pied la
ghana ou de la manière de le mémoriser
vous pouvez vous référer à ses petites
fiches donc n'hésitez pas c'est gratuit
voilà vous savez absolument tout sur les
cils à cana dans la deuxième partie on
va voir les katakana et je vais
également vous donner la petite astuce
pour justement mémoriser sur le long
terme on va parler en l'occurrence de ce
qu'on appelle la courbe de l'oubli cette
notion est très importante car comme je
vous le disais ça va vous servir pour
mémoriser absolument tous quelle que
soit la langue que vous apprenez si vous
faites des études en médecine en droit
peu importe que vous avez des tonnes de
vocabulaire à mémoriser cette astuce va
vraiment beaucoup vous aider à retenir
sans faire ce qu'on appelle du bourrage
de crâne car sachez le bourrage de crâne
ne marchait pas
la vidéo est à présent terminée je vous
dis à bientôt pour les katakana m'isoler
gens
oui
webo
[Musique]